Sophie and I are here to present the
Academy Awards for the fine arts of
sound editing and sound mixing so you
may not always notice their work masters
of both craftsman startled excite and
move audiences in both way that is
enormous ly powerful and subtle here are
the nominees for achievement and sound
editing arrival
Silvan film on deepwater horizon Wiley
stateman and renamed candelas hacksaw
Ridge Robert McKenzie and Andy ready
lala land
Eileen Lee and Mildred iottery Morgan
Sully
Allen Robert Murray and Bob Adams and
the Oscar goes to a rival surrender mara
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Sylvain Delma
[Applause]
[Music]
so they say take a deep breath so I 23
seconds to reduce okay so this award by
far the collective award made by people
from many countries around the world
lead by the Quebec team Alamo Cal and I
want to say thanks to gasp ah your mouth
captain all the cast and the crew from
arrival Amy Adams you a wonderful person
and a profound actress thanks a lot
then if you nerves then you will see I
love you so much
you bring love to us all we need is love
good night
[Applause]